This is such an old saying but it's all about who you know.
The way I got my job in a massive city pub in Brisbane...
...was I overheard some of the girls in the hostel say that...
...this place was looking for someone to come on...
...because a couple of backpackers there were leaving.
So, literally, I was up, went downstairs to the internet cafe,...
...printed off my recent resume and I was out.
And when you get there, sell yourself.
You hear  about job advertisements, you get there immediately...
...and you say, "I heard you're looking for someone."
Even if, you know, even if you haven't...
...but you think that they might  be looking for someone,...
...sell yourself.
Don't ever just ask for the manager and hand over your CV...
...because when I worked in bars and we get people who come in...
...and just pass a CV over, it's not very impressive.
Sell yourself.
Almost demand trial in a very polite way.
Don't be rude now.
No one likes it when you're rude, alright?
You're not gonna get a job being rude, okay?